but I want to get to this clip of
Candace Owens okay I love her Candace if
you're watching please email me okay so
now no she's gonna end up watching this
clip I love her please email me
Candice you've got some fans so
basically
um she talks about this concept of go
make your man a sandwich okay should a
woman go make her man a sandwich go make
your man a sandwich go ahead Candice
Owens what are your thoughts
something that women say to me all the
time why don't you make your husband a
sandwich
okay is he hungry does he want a
sandwich okay did he say something I
make my husband food the last four
nights I've made my husband dinner like
I don't understand this weird maker like
they they're trying to shame women for
taking care of their families like that
is another element of feminism that I
cannot stand there's it's an attack on
family and these things that work it
works men are biologically unable to
have children so the aspiration to climb
a ladder forever to wake up every single
day and and not have to worry about
being pregnant for nine months I mean
that makes sense we're different
creatures you know I think that's like a
troll though no it's like all you're
good for is like yo make me something to
eat no they that whole concept came from
rabid feminists like there was something
wrong with being in the kitchen right
okay and this was sort of this push of
women get out of the home and go to work
which has made so many women miserable
so many women miserable something that
women say to me all okay got it
um we talked about corrections and over
Corrections you know there was a song
that came out uh in
1980 the Dolly Parton song Working nine
two five yeah and all these women wanted
to do was work because there was a
yearning to get out of the kitchen you
know we've seen the show Mad Men and
women were disrespected all that so
correction was needed all right let's
let these women work but now an over
correction is sort of in need where it's
like women are like I gotta get out of
this freaking workplace over here let me
just go be a housewife or be a loving
mother or being a loving
um wife so
um so the con so I think this is really
just a metaphor for the concept of
feminism and what's wrong with feminism
and what's wrong with being a housewife
and you you know you're talking about a
very smart opinionated capable woman
Candice Owens I think we can all agree
with that whether you agree with her
politically or not she's no she's
amazing she's she's pretty
uh she's kind of got it going on but
still she's like yeah I'll make is he
even hungry like I think that's funny
like if like yeah he wants to yeah if
he's hungry I'll make him a sandwich but
uh the bigger question here is this you
know concept of feminism and the over
correction that is probably needed in
society so Ali as a proud housewife and
as a proud anti-feminist right what
about feminism uh bothers you the most
and what's the biggest lie that's being
told to women
I honestly think that just feminism just
cripples women because there is this
whole other sector of Womanhood from an
economic standpoint that you can pursue
outside of an education and that's
something that frustrates me you know in
hindsight now that I've cracked the code
oh wait a minute if I stay relatively
thin and Cooperative you mean that I
have the potential to marry a man that
can take care of me I wish that was
something that I had known sooner I wish
that I didn't feel so crummy in
undergrad when people ask what do you
want to do I'm like well honestly I just
want to be a mom because and I'm about
to sound real gold diggerish but I want
to make it abundantly clear I'm willing
to do whatever my husband asks of me I
very rarely tell him no like y'all can
find him email him DM him so I made more
of the day that I got married than if I
had decided to pursue a PhD and take
that career path for a decade and that
to me is like well why wouldn't I do
that and then I get to do something that
makes me happy because to me my my dream
and I think other women might feel like
this too and if you feel like that then
you know it's okay my dream is more so
to make other people's dreams happen
like my husband's dreams or my kids
dreams that to me a success and I'd
rather take that career path and I can
do that just staying home and taking
care of people and I think that that is
so sad that young women are walking
around and they don't know that that's
an option for them and the other lie
that feminism says is that it's you know
um you have all the time in the world to
get pregnant when in reality it's it can
be a challenge for a third of couples to
get pregnant but it's not just a
challenge to get pregnant it's a
challenge to stay pregnant so if you
look at life beginning at conception
about 70 to 75 percent of pregnancies
end up in spontaneous abortions so your
body just rejects whatever bad DNA
replication occurred right very very
tiny women could be pregnant for like
three days they wouldn't know because
the baby just never comes to fruition if
they're even fertile so women think that
they have this excess amount of time in
reality if you want your best bet in a
man or you want the hot guy who makes a
decent amount of money you have from 18
to 28 to really lock that down so I'll
get you know some skepticism about well
what if this happens to your husband
what if that happens to your husband
honestly I have dual mating strategy
with my husband I have have hypergamy to
the max I'm so grateful like I think
he's hot and he financially takes care
of me I don't want anything else and
girls I mean do it do it at 24 like
screw it marry your professor what do
you have to do
what do you have to lose marry your
doctor about to get a lot of professors
in trouble over there you know I love
how um yeah how all in you are on this
oh yeah single that's true um Sarah uh a
you're gonna make your man a sandwich
yes I I I'm completely we finally taking
care of a man okay that's just that's
that's being a partner I think that
feminism maybe makes women feel bad
about that but that's just like that's
human nature to want to take care of
someone whether they're paying all the
bills or you just love them why wouldn't
you cook for them how often have you had
conversations with women that are like
I'm not [ __ ] gonna make no man a
sandwich I'm not I'm too good for that
like you're saying you have that Italian
motherly nature in you really but do you
ever like butt heads with other women
have completed not about that about
other things maybe
I don't know I mean I can't really think
of anything off the top of the head but
like not about cooking necessarily but
like I do I agree what she said like
feminism does as much as I wanna like
everyone should just do what they want
to be able to do right what they what
they love to do like there was a survey
I took in college and it was like if you
asked a woman if she really wanted to be
a housewife would you be happy working x
amount of years and they'd be like no
then you asked for the flip sign she'd
be like yes and did Vice Versa people
just are going to be happier in the role
that they want to be in you should just
let people do whatever they want to do
but like taking care of your man to make
that to shame women for doing that
that's wrong gotcha respect all right
Leia final word before we wrap up you're
gonna make some man a sandwich one day
or what yes it would bring me all the
joy in the world to cook for my husband
um I'm more than happy too what are you
saying about British people don't cook
well well I'm in the British baking show
I've recently learned some extra cooking
skills I actually hired someone to help
me um like in the kitchen and stuff so
now my cooking skills are really really
good but what I'll say um about all of
that is um I actually don't think like
women are happiest being entrepreneurs
and being in the workplace I really do
think they are happiest um and I don't
not at home I mean they are happiest
when they're in their feminine energy
which means being taken care of but also
taking care of her husband supporting
her husband taking care of children
being nurturing I think that's where
women are most happiest and actually
um sometimes it takes getting much older
and experiencing all of it to realize
like I saw someone doing some Street
interviews about like about this topic
and all these young women were like no I
want a career I want a career it was all
the older women that had done it that
time around I was like no I want a rich
man to take care of me so if you like
that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire sarscast click right here
[Music]